Alright. Welcome to Pod two fifty six episode one two zero. Today is July 15.
We've got Scott,
Tyler, our usual hosts.
And today, a special guest, two fifty six Foundation developer,
Schnitzel,
joins us on the show. What's up, everybody? What's up, guys? Hello.
Hello. Hello. This is exciting. This is exciting times as tends to happen a lot these days, but pretty fired up. And, Schnitzel, yeah, speaking of being fired up, you've been on fire lately doing all sorts of fun developments and bleeding edge cool
projects. So let's hear let's hear about what you've been doing. Yeah. It's been quite an exciting couple of weeks. It's just this like right. As a two fifty six team, we've always talked about what will be possible when we have open source firmware and hardware. And now I feel like, yeah, it's happening. Right? It's there. You can point your AI agents to it, and you can literally dream up an idea, point your AI agents to the hardware and to the software and tell it, hey. Why didn't you build this for me? It goes away an hour later, and it's built. Like, I'm not saying it's production ready, but it's proven that it works. And I and I know we had many discussions as the as the team internally here that, like, this will be possible. Right? This is the future we're talking about. These are all the things we're seeing outside of mining. Right? With open source software, we see all these massive developments that happen with open source software and hardware outside mining with AI. And we always said, like, there just needs to be this little unlock. We need to build these little pieces that are gonna be painful to build, but when we have them, there's gonna be a tidal wave of possibilities.
And that's the wave I'm riding. It's literally like just one idea after the other, and I'm happy to go in what we all have built so far. But, yeah, it's just it's almost this like dream state, I have to say, of, like, just, like, you have an idea, and it just it appears in front of you. So you you've been obviously, you've been totally crushing it lately. I guess you've been crushing it for a while, but there's been a lot of amazing tweets lately about your progress. What what's, like what's the most difficult thing at this point? Not breaking hardware.
Not breaking hardware. Not breaking hardware. So yeah. So what I've been doing mostly,
I started with just basically getting s 19 j pros hashing with the original control board. So, Scott, that was something that you started. Like, you figured out how do we deploy
Mugena on top of these AMLOGIC
control boards. We reverse engineered the exploit that LuxOS and brains
and all the third party firmware are using to install themselves onto these control boards. They are known exploits. You can see them in the code. So we've we figured out the same way, and then this was able to get Machina running. And because it's a Linux,
right, you can figure out how to talk to these hash boards. They're just regular
I squared c interfaces
and all these different things that you use already. They all use the same. So the AI knows how to talk serial through these things.
And, obviously, because
and that's also where it's very cool. While Machina maybe doesn't know exactly how to talk to these chips, the Bidax project has already unlocked
a lot of capabilities. How do you talk to them?
Things like that. And then you can also just tell the the AI, hey. Just go and try. Right? The first you know, I remember the first iteration to get s 90 k boards running. The AI tried for, like, four hours, just continuously try different things and how to talk to these boards. It figured out, oh, there's only 77 chips and instead of a 128. Like, just all these things, the AI is just going and going, and you need to encourage it from time to time. Sometimes it stops and says like, yeah. I think that's enough. And they're like, no, no, no, no. We want us we want all the chips. Done yet.
And so I think that's that's what I've been starting doing. So first, s 19 chase.
But then yeah. So obviously,
right, a lot of this firmware
that we install has a lot of safeguards in it around temperatures
and fan control.
And one of the things that I wasn't aware that the first version
that we installed in Magina just ran the fans at 60%
all the time. And that worked because I only connected one hash board. That worked. And at one point, I was like, hey, let's connect three hash boards. Like, I feel confident. I connect all three. It starts to mine.
All good. And suddenly in the in the eye in the in the viewpoint of my eye, I see like smoke coming out of the of the of the miner, and I run there and plug it out and let everything settle. Like, it's obviously the smell of electrical fire, so it's the the magic smoke we all love and hate. And turn it back on, and, yep, all hash boards do not respond anymore. And then asking the AI again, like, hey, what was going on? And then it's like, oh, yeah. Oh, no. We didn't implement fan control yet. And, yep, we let the fans running at 50 or 60% only. So it's it's that, I would say, is right now is a bit the hardest. It's just trying to reimplement
all the things that by stock firmware and and the third party firmware that totally have implemented, right, measuring the temperature and at updating
automatically
the
frequency or the fans and all these safeguards,
they don't exist because nobody ever built them. But if you're willing to fail, if you're willing to break shit, you can learn from it and and implement. And so, yeah, now today, what I've built is that whenever the temperature of the chips or of the boards get to a specific point, I think it's 60 degrees right now, the miner automatically starts to underclock the chips. Well, obviously, it runs the fans in full speed, and then it underclocks the chips. And then when it gets to 65 degrees, it says, okay. Nope. That's it. And it shuts down the PSU
altogether. So these are like guardrails
that together with the AI, I was like talking through it. Okay. What is possible? What knobs do we have? Things like that. So that for your question specifically, yes. I think right now, the hardest one is just going through all these learnings of unfortunately breaking in hardware.
In software, if you fuck up, then, yeah, you maybe crash the software, and you can try again. In hardware, it sometimes involves broken hardware and in some cases even a fire. Well, I think it's worth highlighting here that we mentioned special guest, by six foundation engineer Schnitzel on the show. He's not even the Mugena engineer. He's the Leap Report engineer,
but it shows what's possible, right, when you have open source. So for for those of us that are listening in and they haven't seen your awesome tweet threads as of late over the past week, what exactly have you built? Yeah. So I took Scott's s 19 j support. I added s 19 k support, not because I wanted, but because I literally broke all my s 19 j's. So I only had case.
And buying a new s 19 j took like a week, and I was like, I have some case lying around. Why not? So so we have now support for s 19 j's and case. I then also because I had one s 19 j left, and I only had two s nine k's, so I built mixed hash board support. So Magina can now run S19Js
and Ks at the same time. Right, we need to understand these need different frequencies and they also have different voltage bands. So Magina realizes
when it boots up it talks to the boards, it figures out oh I have a mixed system. It knows which frequency ranges that each of these boards support and will basically give it only a specific voltage range and frequency range that it can do.
I wanna let this, like, sink in the the
impact of this sink in for our dear listeners. Right? This is one minor control board connected to
basically totally different hash boards. Right? Different numbers of chips on each hash board, different chip models on each hash board. So the the dynamic of controlling each one is
is quite different. The temperature sensors are different. Like, there there's a number of differences here. So having one firmware control multiple
different hash board models
is
is really cool.
This this is this is a major in unlock. I think it it is a testament to the to the modularity of Mugena that that this can be done. Right? It just, you know, understands how to talk to each hash board and then divvies up the work and and controls each hash board based on, you know, what it needs to, to communicate and mine effectively and hopefully not blow up. So this is really cool. Just Yeah. 100%. Yes. This is all possible because Mucina was built from the ground up to support something like this. Right? All other firmwares, they assume
that they have not only the same hashboards, but they assume they have exactly three hashboards. Nothing actually forces us. Like, these control computers, they could easily run four, five, 10. We don't know what the limit is, but it's definitely not three. And, yeah, Ryan built Machina from the beginning to support a lot of different fair lot of different hash boards, like even a CPU one and a bit exe and things like that. And he also built it in a way that he can run all kind of different hash boards with different frequencies, like Scott mentioned, but also different hash rates. Right? Each of these boards, some of them run at 50 terahash, while the other one runs at 10 terahash. So you need to divvy up the work based on how they give you back work. And, like, all that logic is already all there because we have built it from the beginning in that understanding. And so, yeah, I didn't have to build any of this. This was all there.
I just had to teach it or I had to give it time. I basically gave it a couple of hash boards to try, and I told him if you break it, don't worry. I have more. That's what the AI needed. And and yeah. So it just it right. I first did s 19 k individually. I did then s nineteen k individually.
And then I said, okay. Now you have a mixed one. Can you try to figure this out? And what is also really cool, right, it actually comes back and says, hey. This is a bit as scary. Right? I feel I'm writing code. This is now scary. Where do we wanna start? And because I'm telling it, hey. We just broke a hash board. Like, this is like so in this whole context, it does know that things can go wrong, but I also telling it, hey. Look. I'm building this. This is like the first time we're like in this together, and it's really it feels like a partner.
And so he comes back and sometimes says like, look. I'm not really sure if this is gonna work. Can you maybe measure the voltage? So it asks me to connect the multimeter to one specific rail and measure it, and I tell it back, okay. This is, like, 13 volts. And it's like, yay. Okay. Perfect. That's what I expected. Let's continue.
And then it starts at 50 hertz, megahertz of hashing. It goes to a 100 to 200. It runs both of them at the same level. Then it tells me, hey. I'm gonna go I'm gonna divert now. Right? One of them gets more than the other, and I'm saying, yep. It all works. And it monitors the temperature. Obviously, there's code that runs on the machine itself that monitors the temperature, but the AI itself that talks to it also monitors it. So, yeah, it really feels like this extremely
capable
engineer
or partner that I work with that can write code a 100,000 times faster than I can. Well, I I think one of the important things you pointed out is is the modularity and the proper framework in place because with a tool that powerful that can write code that well, you could kind of brute your brute force your way to solve a lot of these problems, I think. We've we've seen people hack into miners and SSH, and there's some other folks that have hacked some some personal
individual firmwares together. Right? And we haven't seen the source of those, so we don't know really how they're architected. When you're starting to talk about support for hundreds of different ASIC systems,
mixing and matching, just think about all the optionality here and then all those features that we want to build that perhaps may already exist and not yet exist on Mugena from the the aftermarket firmware manufacturers. It's like a lot of building blocks. Yep. But the beauty of architecting it properly, and that's why we have these Pugena developer office hours and and Ryan is is maintaining that repo and all you guys are contributing PRs. I mean, the beauty of having it architected, I think, Chinatso, you should probably be able to comment on this is it should help the AI out, right, if Mugena is simple to understand. 100%. Right. I there's multiple times where I can see the AI really
I don't know what work to do, but, like, enjoying to work with Mugena. Right? That it just it's laid out very nicely, like, like, Ryan spent a lot of time making sure, for example, that all the commits are well properly documented, and that's very important. Right? Sometimes the AI needs to go back and look into the history and decide, like, why is it that way? And then having very well commits and documentation in the code itself is extremely important because, yes, it can assume a lot of things. But if you're actually saying, hey. This is why this is done that way. And what is also really nice, it starts to actually behave that way itself.
So I've seen when I'm look at the code that the AI is writing, it actually writes a lot of the assumptions into the code itself and saying, I'm not sure why this works, but it does work. Right? Like and so that's really important because that's something we've always tried to tell software engineers.
Like in the past, without the people that didn't write software without AI, like write your assumptions in it. It's really important.
But a lot of times, right, there's, like, three or four people that maintain the same tool, and that's it. But now with AI, right, we have so many new people if we like, new eyes that look at this code, so it's extremely important to write document as well. And I think the reason that this all works so well is because, correct, like you say, Tyler, it has been architected
correctly from the beginning. It's really cool. Like, you know, this this genius programmer that is the AI has the same benefits from,
you know, clearly architected code that a human would. Right? It can, like, take cues from the existing code and and add in new code in the right way that that keeps with the existing,
I guess, architecture of the code. Right? It's it's just like a human programmer, just way faster. So it's like Correct. If you want, you know, if you want good code, it it helps to start with a good base, right, even even with AI, which is really cool to think about. Yeah. And so yeah. So so from my journey, so we had s 19 j's, s 19 k's. We had mixed support. And then the next step I wanted to do is actual,
specific usage of watts. Right? So I'm actually building all of this in partnership with a company called Riot,
not the Riot US. The Riot, it's r y three t in Switzerland. And they're building an excess solar monetizing system where they basically wanna use excess solar
with Bitcoin mining because not to go too deep in attention here, but, basically, the electrical companies that used to give you money for your all your solar power, it's going back becoming less and less. And next year, in Switzerland specifically, you're actually gonna pay real electrical prices, which sometimes are negative, meaning you're actually gonna have to pay to send back electricity into the grid, which is just like it's the perfect example of government subsidies going wrong. Right? Government years ago said, oh, yeah. You all should build solar panels and overbuild five times. We're gonna pay you. And now it's like, oops. Everybody did it, and now nobody wants the solar panel power anymore because,
like, when the sun is shining, everybody has too much power. Anyway, so so they're trying to build this, and we're trying to build this on Magina. So all my work that I'm doing actually is not paid by the two fifty six Foundation. It's it's done through
this company. But we have an agreement that I'm gonna open source all the stuff we're doing. So that's why it is contributed back to Machina right away. But what they need is, right, they need to to precisely
use a specific amount of watts. So they call it Nova, and that system basically talks to the solar panels or some kind of smart system that the house owner already has. And that system knows, hey. I'm creating right now, I'm generating 2,000 watt too much, or I'm generating 4,000 watts. And that number is given to Nova, and then this system that also runs on the miner talks to Mugena and says, hey, Mugena. Please use 2,000 watts or use 3,000 watts. And that's a system we have seen
from LuxOS and brains
and all the other third party firmware. However, what was very interesting when I asked the AI, can you go and figure out how they do this? It came back and said, like, it actually doesn't know how much watts it really uses. The only information that you have is you have a temperature of the chips, you have the frequency of the chips, and you have the voltage of the chips, but you don't actually have the current or the amps. The PSUs, at least in the s 19 series,
and I think in the newer ones, it's different. But in the older ones, they do not tell you how much power that is current or how much current is currently used. And so it seems, and I'm pretty certain of this, is that basically what they're doing is they buy these miners and test them, their watt usage with an with an external current meter, and they put some curves into this firmware. So they know based on the hash boards and based on the frequency, so the hash board model, the frequency, the voltage, and the temperature, because that's the three variables that basically exist, they can assume how much watts that the miner is using. So if you go to the miner, if you go to a brain through a Luxor and it says, do you use 2,000 watts? It actually is not a 100% sure that it uses 2,000 watts. And I did some tests with brains, and it was come continuously 10% off or sometimes more than 10%. And so what I did now is I actually bought an a current meter. It's a Shelley. It's like a little connector. It has Wi and Ethernet, and it measures the current and has an API. So my Nova code talks to the Shelley now, and and what it does when when I go back and tell tell the Mugena the Nova used 2,000 watts, it also has a curve because I'm having, like, a calibration
step that it tries to figure out the curve. So it sends the Magina a specific frequency and voltage. Again, are the two variables that you actually have come on the control over, where it roughly knows it will probably use 2,000 watts. But then after it goes there, it actually asks the Shelley and says, okay. How much are we currently using? And if the Shelley says, we're using 2,200,
it will then slowly a little bit underclock the miner, or if it says you're using a 800,
it will a little bit over overclock.
And so that so this way I can hit 2,000 watt down to the watt and I can control any watt level. Right? I can go from basically frictionless
from around 800
up to three and a half thousand watts of a miner. I can I can set any watt level, and I can hit it? So before this took depending on the firmware, it either wasn't possible with certain OEM firmwares or it was slow or it would require a reboot, say you wanted to go from 3,000 to 2,000 watts, it might go to zero first Yes. Before going back to 3,000. It might take forty minutes. That's the case with many watts miners. Tell us how and that wasn't even real wattage as you just elaborated.
So now you have precise wattage control. How long does that take? So that's the really strange thing. Right? I, again, I asked the AI and said, hey. Let's implement this system that we automatically can adapt. The Magina already does a frequency ramping. Like, when you start these chips, right, you can't just like, some of most of them run at, like, thirteen, fourteen volts per hash board, and
that then gets divided through all the chips, and the frequency is between
500 to 700. Depends a bit on the chips. If you run them from the beginning with five seven hundred, they will not start. So you actually have to start with 50, a 100, a 150, 200. Like, you have to ramp them up. And Magrino already has this because in order to get the running by the way, the Bidax ESP Miner does exactly the same. So this was already known that we have a frequency that needs to go up. And so when I told the miner or I told the AI, hey. I need now need to have a frequency thing. It already knew, oh, I can't immediately jump there. I need to do a frequency ramping. What is really interesting though, the initial frequency ramping that goes from zero to 700,
it only took like thirty seconds. So I always felt like, wait. So if you go from zero to 700, you should be able to go from 500 to 700, like in ten ten seconds or twenty seconds. Right? Like, it should not require
what the current frameworks are doing, which is basically shutting down completely and starting from scratch again. They start from zero. Restart from zero. That's what they do. And so, yeah, again, I just I interact with it and said, okay. Let's go let's first implement the going from lower to higher because we know this is possible. And it took, like, three seconds. And I was like, okay. So
Mhmm. I guess you don't need to do this. And so and I was like, okay. Now, let's go the other way around. Like, let's go from 700 to 500, and I and it asked me how fast you wanna do it. I was like, well, let's do the same speed. And I did it the first time, and it went from 700. That's like from from 3,000 watts to 2,000 watts. And I literally looked at the curve on it. I can see in my tool. I can see what the target like, set point is, and the frequency, like, within two seconds was there. And then, like, the adjustment happened. And I looked at this and it's like, what is going on? But, like, we've asked we've asked for this since years and wondered why is it not possible, and it turns
out that these firmware just didn't implement it. Like, it's the hardware is totally capable to switch from any watts to any other watt level within sometimes two seconds, worst case, maybe ten if you have a very wide range. And there's no need to stop mining.
There's no need to restart
anything. You can just go there. And so, yeah, if you go on my tweet, on my on my x, there's videos there that I'm showing it because, honestly, I did not believe in myself. Yeah. If you know, you know. Those videos were amazing to see it. It it responds so fast. And that's very important for the project you're talking about, Schnitzel, which is, you know, following your solar generation curve, your excess generation, which can actually change quite quickly if a cloud comes through or something Yep. Which
is a struggle if you have a slow responding miner. Scott, we've been talking about ramping for a long time and and you understand the actual the chip interface better than most. Why do you think these firmware manufacturers have not implemented that feature that Schnitzel just talked about? I think it's because of the intended use case for the firmware. So if you think if you're doing industrial mining, which is what all the third party firmwares are targeting, efficiency is basically all that matters. Because if you're not mining efficiently,
you're you're losing money. And so they take this this,
frequency ramping
very carefully,
very carefully. The the issue that you have is all these chips are powered in series. There can be 10 chips connected in series. And so that's taking, let's just say, 12 volts and dividing it by 10 for each chip's individual core voltage. That'd 1.2 volts per chip. But the only thing that determines what the voltage across each chip is when they're powered in series,
Right? Because you have these floating points in the middle. You have these floating they're called voltage domains, but you have these floating points in the middle that that essentially divide up that 12 volts by 10. And the only thing that actually sets those midpoints is the voltage drop across
a particular chip. And that voltage drop across a particular chip is dependent on the current that that chip is drawing, which is dependent on its hash frequency, like, entirely. And so when you're you're trying to set up this voltage stacking, this division across all the chips, you do need to, like, Shinsel said, you do need to ramp up the hash frequency because that's what controls essentially the voltage drop across each chip. You wanna ramp that up slowly so that the voltage drop across each chip is the same, so it's even. It's kind of like you need to, like, ease into it. If you But we just saw that slow
is not that slow, though. Right? It's not as slow too fast. You think. I see. If you go too fast, the risk is that it will be uneven. The voltage drop across each chip will be uneven. And you can get into this situation where if the first ones in the stack are dropping too little voltage, then that relies on the later ones, the lower ones in the stack, to drop the rest. And so you could get into a situation where you have 12 volts on the input and, you know, the the first ones are only dropping point six volts, and now you have to drop multiple volts across the last one. You can So this impacts your efficiency of all the chips? Yeah. So in the extreme case, you can damage them. In the the less extreme case, they can operate much less efficiently.
Right? So you have, you know, these these lower chips that have much higher voltage across them, and they essentially have to burn that extra power doing the same amount of work. And so that's more power for the same amount of hash rate that's less efficient. So I think that the stock firmware
and the third party firmwares are taking it really slowly because they care about efficiency.
Like, only. They only care about efficiency. But, you know, what we're doing here is pushing miners into different use cases. Right? There's different things that we care about. And in in an in an installation like this where it's powered by solar, if you are attempting to draw too much current, like, the whole system will not work. Right? So what's more important here in this case is following
your input power closely. Because if you try and draw too much from your solar panels or whatever system is powering this, it's just not going to work at all. So you're down to zero hash rate. And so I think that if we care about efficiency a little bit less and more, we care more about closely tracking the power,
yeah, we can ramp faster. That's, that's the important factor, right? Is to get to that power to remain alive as soon as possible.
Yeah. Efficiency may suffer. I mean, might be what we're seeing. I don't know. We we could look into it. Efficiency may be suffering by going faster through this this ramping phase, but that isn't that, you know, that could be fixed later too. Right? You could imagine like, all right, we gotta get to this lower power. Boom. Go as fast as we can. Okay. Now now we can work on essentially tuning the chips to get back to that efficiency.
So it's it's kind of a matter of priorities. But I think that's the whole name of the game for this project. Right? We're we're taking this firmware that is purpose built for one task only, which is, like, on grid mining efficiently as possible. And we're saying, like, no. No. We care about other things. And Mugena, you know, has the ability
for people, agents, whatever to adjust and kind of target these different use cases, of which this is one we've been talking about for a long time. And so I think that's really neat. There's still a lot we don't know about these chips. Right? They're famously undocumented.
So it is cool to try these things and learn how the chips respond
and then kinda put that back into the global knowledge base of of how these operate. And that that's a that's a win for everyone. Yeah. And that's what I'm doing. Right? I I'm not saying that the ramping in three seconds will be what we're gonna end up with. What I'm literally doing, like, every night when I go to bed, I tell the AI, hey. Here are three miners. Just go through the free like, go frequency,
ramp them up and down, like, simulate
the usage of an of a solar panel. The really good thing is most of these installations, they actually have well, a, they have batteries.
So you have some kind of like, it's not that you need to go from three to 1,000 back to 3,000, 1,000. Like You got a damper.
You have a damper. Correct. Or you can use the grade as a damper itself.
And plus, again, right, we're talking about it. It looks pretty good. Like, it's a nice curve that you can go up and down very slowly. But, yeah, that's the part that I'm doing now is stress testing these things. That's why I'm actively asking for people. If you have any hash boards that you don't need anymore, send them to me because I believe I'm gonna kill a lot more while doing this stress testing. And so that's also if people ask, like, where's the code? Where's the code? I wanna try this. The code is there. It's on the GitHub rep post. But, right, this is bleeding edge. You will melt.
You will have fires. You will cause issues in your whatever you're trying to do. So this is not fully tested, validated system yet. It shows the capabilities,
the possibilities.
But in order to get there, we're really gonna need to spend a lot more time testing. But I'm up for it. And if other people, they already reached out. So if you wanna test as well, I'm happy to explain to you how this works. If you have a Claude agent, I can literally give them an an instruction how to install it, which is really cool. So I can tell my agent can tell your agent how to do this. And so, yeah, that's that's what I see as a next step is we're we're gonna need to test this. Because right now, I mostly test with S19Js
and K chips.
But it could be, right, as Scott says, even a specific model version within these
hash boards, like the hash boards have models, they are differently layout. We also know that within the chips there's different revisions of the chips itself, and then there's obviously different chips
generations altogether,
and each of them could behave completely differently. So that's now is about, okay, we've shown it's possible, and now let's stress test. Like put it on the dyno in terms of cars,
Right? Or in airplanes or whatever, you would like you would do stress tests. You would do stall tests and all that stuff. Right
now, we've just shown the plane can fly. We don't know exactly what the limits are of this system that we're working with, and that's what I'm gonna test. There's a the there's each hash board from Bitmain since the very beginning has an EEPROM on it. And that EEPROM is loaded from the manufacturer with some information
about what's on the hash board. It is encrypted, which is really unfortunate, but there's been a bunch of work to figure out how to decrypt that from from a you know, a lot of people across the industry have have kind of figured that out. So I think as we're looking into these different hash boards, it would be neat to look into the EPROM EPROMs on them as well and figure out how we can use that information to to gather some,
you know, idea of how to interface with the particular chips that are on that hash board. Yeah. So, yeah, my end goal is to basically make, like, a bit of, like, a Magina test bench version. So that's gonna be a special version of Magina that has code in it specifically for understanding what hash boards are there and going through their
capabilities. And there might probably be, like, more a safe version if you don't want to kill your board or there's maybe gonna be more the extreme version where you can tell Magina, hey, don't actually care. Like like or I don't care. Like, try to push it as far as you can in terms of temperature and things like that. And actually one of the things I'm also thinking about this right now, right, this all The AI is actually executed on my computer and it talks with the Mucina running on the on the miner. What I'm trying I haven't started yet, but I actually wanna run the AI on the board itself so that the harness runs on Mucina itself because then you have even faster. Because right now there's a little bit of delay. I had situations where my computer, cloud code, or whatever you're using, because it can only talk to the to the chip from time to time, there's no, like, interrupting or whatever. Like, you couldn't say, hey. If the chip goes to one specific temperature, immediately call the agent and tell it, hey. This is going on. Right now, my agent talks, every ten seconds to the to Magina. But if something happens within that ten seconds that destroys it, it's already gone. And so the idea is how could we get the AI closer to the board that it could be, for example, interrupted? Like, if it's doing some frequency ranges and it says, hey. Hey. The temperature is now very high. Stop what you're doing. That could be a lot better. So a lot of ideas there, but my end goal is really that if people are out there willing to help that they can install a specific machine attach bench version on their miners that then go through it, gathers all that information and like Scott mentioned uploads it to the hive mind that we know
what each hash board can do, what are their capabilities,
frequency ranges, temperature ranges,
adaptability like changing
all of that. But because we don't know what the chips can do, the only way, unfortunately, is to just try and error, and unfortunately, gonna break some boards.
And that's just the only way to do it. Man, I just like, I love this test bench idea. This is super fucking cool. But I was imagining
cause Tyler, you were getting me hyped up the other day on these like AI,
you know, like brains,
like these stores of information that an AI has collected that an AI can then also reference.
Mhmm. What if we had a public one of those that just is collecting all this data that, you know, people across the community are discovering and puts it in an easily AI reference
database?
I don't know how that would work, but, you know, you could imagine, like, creating you know, companies are getting all excited. Block is famously doing this about creating these company brains, right, where they just are depositing everything that everyone in the company knows so that all the people working there can have their agents access it and, like, work faster. Right? But, you know, we're not a company. We're, you know, we're a bunch of open source hackers. Like, is this something that we could make? Like, some sort of evolving brain of all this information?
My god. That would be so fun, Grant. Most certainly. And it's especially helpful to your point, Shnitzel, when there's so many versions and revisions of chips and different hash board model numbers. I think that was even something that you had you
had to do differently than Scott's s 19 Mugena firmware a little bit ago. Right? You you realized you had a different version. Yeah. There's main one big difference, so it's just they call them pick or no pick. So I think in the beginning, Scott correct me, I think the first versions had a pick and then later on they stopped doing that. But basically, if you have a pick, means that you can actually turn on and off a hash board individually.
Right? So you give it 12 to 15 volts, whatever whatever the firmware decides, and then this runs through the through the board. And the initial versions of hash boards, they actually had think about an on off switch again per hash board. And that makes a lot of things easier. Specifically,
you can, for example, if well, one, you can turn off a hash board if you want to, or if it's broken, the other two can still run. However, and I think that is obviously like a cost. That is a cost on the chip or on manufacturing
it. So I think what Bitmain realized is that it's actually not necessary. Right? They became a lot better over time. They became a lot better in controlling them and not killing them, not killing the boards. So they removed the picks. And that means you cannot turn on and off a hash board anymore. You can actually see it in the firmwares in Luxor and Brains. You can see there's like an experimental mode to still run it even though it doesn't have a pick. The problem is electricity most probably might still flow through the board depending on how it broke. And so we could actually make whatever is broken, make it way worse down to like create fires as I've already done. And so but the difference is how you talk to these boards is very different because if you have a pick, the first thing you have to do is you first have to talk to the pick and saying, hey. Can you please turn on? And then the chips are energized.
With a non pick version, they're already energized. So the time that they expect work or when you need to talk to the chips is or to the boards is very different in terms of like when you when you turn on the power supplies and the voltage comes and like all. This is this is a specific step that you have to do stuff. And depending on if you have a pick or not, yeah, it does it's different.
Yeah. So thinking about those different hardware features and and optimizing for maximum efficiency at the lowest cost is I think how modern ASICs are optimized. With your Shelley experiment on the RIOT Nova, did that lead to the conclusion that we would rather have direct current measurement on the hash boards themselves? I mean, I would claim the more data, the better. Right? It will be really good if we have a a current measuring in the power supply itself. In the power supply. Because the power supply also has an efficiency.
Mhmm. If you draw,
let's say, 3,000 watts from the wall, meaning outside what what goes into the PSU, it doesn't mean that you send 3,000 watts to the chips or to the hash boards because the PSU itself has an inefficiency. And you need to call if if your end goal is, like in my case, I wanna draw 2,000 watts from the solar panels, and I don't actually really care if I use it in an efficiency loss in the PSU or I lose it like the the control board itself uses a little bit, the fans use some power of it. Right? There's all these other consumers. I care about the 2,000 watt at the end. So, yes, having a current measurement in the PSU before it even goes into the PSU itself would be very good. And then having one off the output side, right, on the 12 volt side would be really good because then we could calculate the the loss of the freak of the of the PSU itself. And then, yes, per hash board would also be really cool because then we can even tweak the efficiency even better. And while we're on it, as Scott mentioned, one per frequency domain or one per chip will be superb
because then we can fit check. Are we doing these voltage drops correctly? And that could be like predictive maintenance to saying, hey, something weird is happening over there. But we're not there. Right? Unfortunately,
there are all the things that I described do not exist, at least in the s 19 generation.
I think in the 21.
I think, Scott, they added some more there.
Now The, the s 21. So not the s 21 pro and not the s 19 XP. So just the s 21 with the b m thirteen sixty eight chips actually had voltage and temperature measurement capability per chip digitally. It's really weird. I don't know why they didn't have it before and why they got rid of it after that, but that could be a good test case Yeah. Is to use an s 21.
That'd be great for the Mugena test bench. Yeah. Yeah. But we can obviously, like what I did, I put a Shelley. There are ways that we could make
harnesses,
like physical harnesses that you could attach
to an s 19 to get that data. Like, the voltage is there or the current is there. There are little chips. They are like these coils that you can put, like the wires through specific coils that measure. They're also like near field chips that you could basically place on top of the rails to measure that. Like, it's all capable.
It obviously just will involve hardware modification.
So, yeah, I could see that there's maybe while we're naming things, there's a TestBench Plus
that actually gives Mucina
or the TestBench
system all kind of access to these measurings.
But I think right now, like, we don't even know anything really what these boards can do. I think we can figure out a lot without that. And then as we went wanna become more and more efficient, yes, actually making hardware modifications to get even better data out would I I think that's gonna happen. I'm imagining a cool project that replaces the busbars with sort of our own circuit that could then it could do two things. It could enable you to turn off power to hash boards individually, and it could also monitor the current to each hash board.
That'd be pretty cool. That would be awesome. Speaking of some other things that you showed this past week, Schnitzel, and those awesome threads on Twitter, I think I saw that this software that is trying to target that communication loop, right, between the Shelly and Magina, right, for the the solar monetizing system, that feedback loop there, This is running on a stock control board. What's the microcontroller here? Yes. So in the past,
right, whenever you wanted to do something, you basically had to, like that's what I built. That's what HassMiner is about. That's the home assistant thingy. So you need to have a home assistant with a Raspberry Pi, and that then talks to the API through the miner. But basically what Scott figured out is how to deploy Macino on these control boards. That means we can deploy a lot more. Like, you it's a Linux computer. It can run multiple software at the same time. And so, yeah, what I figured out is why do I need to build another Raspberry Pi if I make the Nova solution, which again is built by in Rust, and it literally just talks to some APIs of the solar systems, and it talks to the API of Magina, and it has a storage of the curves. Like, that's what it is. I can just tell my AI, hey. I want you to target this specific control board with that Linux version. I mean, don't even have to tell it. I just give it XSH access, and it figures out itself what is running on it. And it can build it. And because we're building using Rust, which you can binary compile in all kind of different programming hardware or computer solution. Right? So this is not like Python or anything that you first need to install it. You can literally binary build it for that specific software and hardware. And, yeah, I can just directly deploy it. So that means in the Nova system, the idea is that you have the first miner that you get. There's a 3,000 watts, you can use up to 3,000 watts. And it runs Machina on the control board, but also the Nova software itself on the same control board. We're actually powering the control board twenty four seven. So by default, right, the PSU runs the control board
and and the miner.
What we're actually doing is we're replacing the or we give the control board individual power, so it runs 20 fourseven even though the miner is technically turned off or the PSU is turned off.
And then it talks to the solar panels and uses up to 3,000 watts. If you want to use more and at least for the customers that we talk to some of them have up to six, seven, sometimes 20,000
watts of excess solar panels or power. You can then basically put additional NOVAs on top, but they will then not run NOVA anymore, the controller software. They will just run Magina. And the main one, the first one, will tell the other ones what to do. So it becomes like this hive mind, and that's what one of the video is about that you actually
Master slave model. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. So you talk
you just talk to the first one, and that's the craziest thing. Right? I can talk to the first one, and it knows,
okay. I need to use, let's say, 8,000 watts right now. And each of the miner has a calibration step. So when you add a new Mugena to the Nova software,
it has no idea. Right? It doesn't know what it can do. So you calibrate it, and it goes as the miner as a whole, not individual hash boards as the miner as the whole. It goes through different frequency ranges and figures out, oh, this miner can use from, let's say, the minimum is 500 watts, the top is 2,000 watts or 2,500.
And and then the Nova itself, if it if it gets a request, hey. Use 8000 watts.
You can tell it. Do you wanna use the first one full? Like, you wanna fill that one and then the next one may be half full? Or do you wanna balance it out across
all of them? So it will automatically, depending on what you want, it can give it can basically distribute the electrons across all these three miners.
But it doesn't actually have a way to distribute it. Like, the only thing that it can tell it is run with that frequency. That's the only knob it has. But because it went through this calibration step, it knows what it will use depending on the frequency.
And so it can control. It can basically yeah. It becomes this orchestrator.
And I can literally go from 1,000 to 9,000 watt in, like, twenty seconds. Just think about this. This is a Bitcoin miner running software so that the miner can turn on other Bitcoin miners. Yeah. Yeah. And there and I don't see a reason why this cannot be scaled up. Right? We're talking about, yeah, like,
massive industrial.
Right? I'm not an energy expert at all, but based on what I've learned on listening to podcasts of people that are,
like, that's an actual value that you can provide back to the grid if you work in the grid or, like, in terms of, like, gridless,
right, that try to do small grid systems. That's an extremely valuable capability if you have a system that can change their consumption
predictably
within a couple of seconds. Like, suddenly, you can start to level out or handle spikes,
and all of this was never really possible
at least for the middle size. Like, they're very big miners. They always had the capability. The ones with 10,000 miners, they will always be able to just turn 3,000 miners off if they wanted to. Right? If they suddenly had to reduce by 33%,
you just turn off 33% of the miners. But if you only have two miners Yeah. The resolution is reduced by 20%. You can't because the the
it's too coarse. Like, the changes that you can do is either zero fifty or a 100. And this now allows even in smaller scale the capability to go up and down. And that's obviously
the own that's massively needed for solar power. Right? Because you wanna prevent that you ever take more energy from the grid because that's freaking expensive. But I think, yeah, this will open up so many more capabilities,
not only for home mining, but for small industrial or even for very big. Because the other thing is, if you actually have it's actually more efficient to downscale
on those 10,000 miners. Right? If you wanna get rid of 33%,
it's actually better to underclock all of them by 33%
than turning off 33%.
Because we know the more on the clock these miners are, the more efficient they become, meaning they have more hash rate for the power usage. So I'm glad you said that because
you just tied it into how it it can also be a a feature set, a benefit to the large scale miners. And I wanna ask, this is a question anybody, Eco chime in as well. This is a really cool example of a two five six foundation engineer and someone kind of focusing on specific feature sets and problems to solve for this solar problem that exists this way in Switzerland, which is fantastic. Why would you not do that? How are we as the foundation I mean, is the hope and the dream that everybody goes and solves their unique problem. Right? But how do we know what gets merged into Mainline Mugena and what kind of stays off to the side? Because it's awesome to hear that Riot wants to keep this software open source. I'm just curious to the team. Maybe it'd be helpful for the audience to kinda get an explanation of that. Anyone? Yeah. I mean, I'm I'm talking to Ryan about this. Right? Like, right now, all this work that I'm doing is done in my own fork of Mugena on my on the Schnitzel GitHub account. You can find it there. All the code is there. And, of course, yes, the really big question is, okay, what now makes it into mainline Magina? And for anybody to that knows, like, that's that's the process we want. Right? That is how good software is built, that you don't just let any crazy person like me that just tested one thing one time and it worked. Let's build it into Magina on there. Right? So Ryan
slightly changes now his role. He he was from
the initial creator
to now he is now you could call it, like, the guardian of Machina itself. And I'm writing all this code, and he is looking at it now and decides these are the things that we can take in. Right? And it's totally possible that he says, I'm taking it all, or he takes 50%, or he takes only 10%. Right? That's but that's okay.
That's what we want because Mucina needs to you don't want every feature in Mucina that somebody can just think about because there's so many more possibilities. Like, just because it's not in Magina doesn't mean you can't have it. You can fork Magina. You can build an additional tool. Like this the system that controls three miners at a time at the same time, that's not built into Magina. I built a separate software that does this. And so that's now the process of us as we're hearing all these use cases that we need to decide as as Ryan specifically,
but as a $2.56 foundation, but also as a group. So if you're interested in this discussion, join the dev calls because that's what we're talking about there is what should we now put into there and what should stay externally. But because we use the proper open source licenses, it will always be available.
It might not just be not in machine in two fifty six Magina. It might be in Riot Magina or in Schnitzel Magina. But that's okay because the other really good thing is these agents are really good in handling git and different repositories.
So you could totally in the past, this was very hard. Right? Different forks, it was a pain to bring them together and stuff like that. Now with AI, you can just tell it, hey, take this feature from the Schnitzel version and take this version from whatever the two fifty six found a version
and build me my own Magina. Bam. Done. And you can just run it. Yeah. I mean, this this is the problems that any open source project has. Right? Linux is a good example. Right? It it interfaces
specifically with hardware.
And so there's all sorts of new CPUs and peripherals coming out all the time. And the vendors and manufacturers of those those hardware projects, you know, they will immediately fork Linux
and and add their features. And then, you know, that stuff is is made public if they're following the license. So anyone can see how they're doing it. And then, you know, Linus and the rest of the crew, core maintainers on Linux, you know, they have the the job of figuring out what they wanna merge into mainline Linux. It's it's not so much, like, censorship as is just, like, organization.
Yeah. Right? Because it's if they say, no, we're not merging this in, like, that's just not part of our project,
that doesn't doesn't, like, remove that from the the public knowledge base. Right? It's still out there. So it's it's a pretty
Right. They're kind of choosing defaults. Like, this is what you get as default with mainline Linux. This is what you get as default feature set with mainline Magina. This is not to say if you want the specific feature, you can grab it elsewhere.
And it's like in my in my experience, like, run field companies with open source software. It's very common that you might not find this feature yet.
Like, we use a lot of Kubernetes. There's many features that five years ago we needed. We built it ourselves, and then the community we contributed it back. The community munched through it, and it took them three years. But now it's part of Kubernetes. And so we had we were able to remove
our own code from it. Right? And so you just as a prop like, this is how open source works. Like, you you will always run slightly different versions or that are modified.
Important is that you always be able to go back to it. Right? And so that's and I'm also aware that as we're talking about this and if some of the big Bitcoin miners are are listening at this and it's like, what the hell? Now they're saying, like, I need to run my own code and my own forks. Like, I'm just used to talking to one company and tell them what I want and they build it. Like, how do I get this back? And and I think that's a very important part because as as February, right, we're we're talking to these big miners, and they have a lot of other problems. Right? The problems that we're solving, yes, there's some of their problems, but they they have a lot more problems that they need to worry about. And I understand that they're like that this can feel overwhelming.
What I can say is that, well, some companies figured out, for example, Mara, they built their own control board. Like, I have one of them. They gave me one. So, like, they went so far that they realized to do this properly, we need to build our own firmware and our own control board, which is awesome to see. So a, if there's precedents that companies are doing this, and there's a reason because they know that they can get more efficiency. But on the other side, and that's also something that we're talking about, right, that we might also need to have companies that actually provide such services to these end customers. So I told like, Red Hat in the Linux world and in the Kubernetes world is the best case for this. Right? You can call Red Hat and saying, I wanna use all the capabilities of open source, but I want zero worry. Like, you manage it for me. You do the forking for me. You do the main line and lobbying and, like, all that stuff. So I do think that there will be companies that do the same because I can understand why these big miners maybe say, like, I just I don't have the team for it. I don't have the time. I just need the firmware that can work, that does the stuff that I need. But the really cool thing is what we're building here actually unlocks this. Because right now, there's the only two count three companies, Mucina sorry, Brains, LuxOS, Vanish, that really knew how to do this. And they and I saw some of the contracts. Right? You couldn't just talk to LuxOS and saying, can you write me a custom firmware? They also wanted you to use their pool,
and then
there were some hardware deals involved. Like, it just becomes very murky and, like, like, all these deals that nobody really wants, but because that's all there is. That's the only thing they can do. And I think now with open source, we can now have custom open
mining firmware companies that built for a big miner or a small miner, like I'm doing now for Riot, a custom version for their specific use case. And I think that's extremely cool. I think the the Red Hat of Magina is it's I think it's inevitable.
But it's also a fantastic idea and and also an opportunity to make lots of money. Right? There's these big miners.
You know, they want to buy their way out of their problems.
And I think the firmware can solve that, but they're not gonna solve it for themselves. Right? They want to pay someone to do it and to be there when something's not working and call. And those are all things you can charge for. So this is a really good example of making real money on top of free software. It's
providing those value the services that your clients want.
And there's also not just gonna be one company. Right? The Red Hat is one of them. Mhmm. There is thousands of Red Hats in the world. Right? This is because, right, you maybe have specific specification.
Like, we're probably gonna have a Machina Red Hat for
solar power or for district heating or for a most efficient way of mining. Right? There's so many subsections
within this mining as we're seeing how these miners are literally gonna be used. To plug one thing, Scott and I were actually gonna be on Friday in in in
in Popkin DC, and I'm giving a presentation about all these different use cases of mining which don't have anything to do with efficiency mining. And I I found so many already out there that is really exciting to see. And I think Mugena and open source firmware is gonna unlock even more of them because it just it just does not make sense anymore to basically just heat for heat sake. You should also mine at the same time. I think showcasing what Mugena can do helps break this ephemeral nature of what a Bitcoin miner might think firmware is. Even the large institutions,
I mean, we we we joked about this when we were all together in Vegas. It's like you talk to some of these big ass Bitcoin mining companies, and they don't know how mining works. Not all. Some folks at the company do. And and I know it's a it's a complex thing, and it might not be that person's role. But, you know, the relationship goes from, hey, can you build this complicated thing for me? And they might say, that's not how it works. You have to use our pool or that's not possible. And you go, okay. It's not possible.
To now, you can go, I'm just gonna hire a dev to look at the source code and tell me if it's possible and build me exactly what I want. There's no more man in the middle. Yeah. And it's so funny to me. Right? This is the same
journey that we went through with Microsoft
and Linux. It's the same journey that is happening in hardware. Right? It's just as if you have been in this field for long enough and I can clock now around twenty years in in professional
IT, you just see the same behavior again and again. You can start to predict what's happening, which is obviously very exciting. And sometimes it's actually lucrative. Not sure how it is lucrative here right now, but in some places it is. It would be great if there is like a poly market to predict
when bitmain is gonna die or when
all The US miners will be required by the US government to use open source firmware because we don't actually know what's happening in all this firmware. I'm pretty sure there's shady stuff happening. So a couple of predictions that I think we should do. But no, it's the same. It's the same open source eating the world. It happened so many times, and it's going to happen again. And this case, obviously, it's really exciting to be at the forefront and actually push this forward. So It's amazing. It's so exciting. It's so exciting. And it And so to talk a bit more about the future. Right? So we have we have mixed sports. We have full wattage following
not only per miner but across multiple miners. One of the next things I'm really trying to do is tuning per chip.
We haven't talked about this a lot yet, but right now, right, you tell each of the hash board run-in that frequency.
But actually, you can tell each of the chips to run-in a slightly different frequency. And so what you're doing is you're it's trial and error that you basically change the frequency a little bit up and down, and you look how the hash rate is changing of the whole board of or of the int like, you're not looking at a hash board. We're looking at how many, how many nonces come back. And based on that, each of the chips, right, not maybe all of them need to run at 500 watts. Some of them need to run at 510, other needs at five 490.
The other thing we need to understand is the cooling,
specifically in air cooled, the chips closer to the fans are colder than the fan than the chips at the out at the exit. And we know which chips is where because we know how they're lined up. So and, again, as I mentioned before, the efficiency
aka the wattage is is depending on the temperature. So it could totally be that you can push the chips closer to the fans a little bit harder because they're cooler than the ones in the back which are warmer. And so that's another thing. So we could act if we talk about efficiency right right now, I'm not optimizing for efficiency, but a 100% agree what Scott mentioned before,
my expectation is that Magino will go as fast as he can to the required watts, and then within a band that you give it, it will start to optimize. It will use the same amount of watts overall, but the efficiency aka the hash rate or the joules per terahash will go up. And that's in the end is how we make money. Right? 50 terahash compared to a 100 terahash is double the amount of money at the end of the day or the amount of SATs. And I haven't started with this at all. It's not a field that I know a shitload, but we're gonna figure it out with the agents together. Yeah. You are. Because that's kind of every every individual chip finding its sweet spot. Right? And which remind me, guys, which variable stays constant? If you want a constant wattage here, would it be the voltage and you're just adjusting the frequency of each chip?
Yes. So the voltage is the thing that is the same
across
all the hash boards because there's one power supply that feeds all three hash boards. Now there's another thing I wanna try. And the voltage drop thing that Scott talked about Correct. Across each ship. Yes. Another thing that I could try is, like, you could have a hash board a a power supply per hash board. It would totally work. Magina can talk to multiple hash power supplies at the same time. Now it will again Well, that the ProtoRig has three power supplies, which is interesting, and one control board. Exactly. And nine hash boards. Yeah. Yeah. And so but right now, I'm trying to do little hardware modifications
as possible. But, yeah, I could see, like, that's one we are talking in the in the Riot system. Like, we're actually thinking about what minimal hardware changes can we do to optimize this even more. And one of the idea, we haven't built it in any way, but, yeah, is maybe to have different power supplies per hash board because then, yes, you could do optimize per hash board a k a and then all the chips. But, yes, as soon as you as soon as you find a state and it's about tuning efficiencies, yes, you can only tune the efficiency per chip, but you also can't do too much. Like Scott mentioned before, you can't run one of the chips with only a 100 megahertz and the other one with 500
because then the voltage drop problem again. So it's all connected to each other. Unfortunately,
or just there is a fact that that information
of per chip tuning, that's something you can only figure out per hash board. Right? So that's something that needs to happen on the on the Mucina or on the actual miner itself. All the other things we talked about, the frequency ranges and the voltage ranges of the hash boards,
that is per hash board model. So that information we can share with each other. The individual chip tuning is something that will need to happen on the miner itself. So that will basically be either or another tool. After it is running, you say, okay. Now start to optimize,
and it will actually store that information somewhere. But that information of which chip runs at which frequency is specifically on how much voltage and frequency and each hash board. So you'll save this per serial number of the hash board. That's why I haven't really focused on this because, yes, it will squeeze out more efficiency, but it's it's gonna be a process that people will need to run, and this is gonna take some time. Yeah. Yeah. It's a complex thing to solve. I mean, it's like having hundreds of little engines where you gotta get the fuel pressure and the RPM of each one dialed in. And then how you impact the first one tells you how much fuel is remaining for the next one in series. Right? That's really what it is. Yep. Yep. And that's that's very similar. Like, if you look at SpaceX launching 31 rockets and the 31 engines, right, on a massive rocket, each of them affects all the other ones around because of the heat and the vibrations and all of this. Right? So this is this is a system that, yeah, everything affects each other. But what is really cool, like, a lot of these things are basically trial and error, where you're just gonna spend in old days, you literally had to just go in it and change it and see how it reacts,
temperature, look at this, and go back and change it, and like that was manual work. Now, I can tell an AI agent, you have eight hours, go. And I go to sleep. And by the way, here's a Shelley, if you ever feel in insecure or something is wrong, here's a power supply, here's a power off. You can turn yourself off if you feel like something is going out of range, and that's what I'm literally doing all night. I just go to bed and tell it, hey, go play. And I come back and some of these AI runs, they've literally run for eight hours until I come back, and and they found something new. And it's always very excited to tell you what it figured out overnight. So yeah. Yeah. What other tips? Go ahead, Scott. This test bench needs to have, like, a, this, like, fail safe. Right? Probably tied to temperature,
but, like, maybe even an independent loop running somewhere that's just, checking the temperature. If it gets above this, cut the power. Like Yeah. That's your that's your, you know, your your fire extinguisher. Yeah. I imagine it's like what what I think of
is this kind of like you see those engine dynos where there's a million sensors connected to it? It's all probed, then they run it, and they can measure everything. Is that what the test bench would be here in this scenario? You know, Ryan does this. He's got a really cool setup for this is for lower power stuff like control boards and things. Right? But he has this whole harness that he can sort of automate to independently measure a bunch of things, switch things on and off. It gets a little bit tougher with this stuff because it's it's much higher current, so the switches get much more heavy duty, but that could be a neat thing to set up. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I could really see the test bench is maybe just a software, like I said, and there's, like, a the safe version where it's not gonna go to the edges.
And then, yes, we maybe have a test bench hardware actually
where you plug your miner in and it has temperature sensors and temperature fuses and all that stuff that it can really, really push it. But I wanna know. Like, I've heard for the longest time that these chips cannot run more than 90 degrees, and I don't believe it. I don't think that's true. Like and I wanna figure out. Like, I wanna see I wanna see until it breaks, then we know. And, obviously, it's really helpful that right now these miners are very cheap. I mean, rather than selling dirt cheap, you still pay, like, a $102,100 bucks per for each of them. But we obviously can also work with individual hash boards. Like, I do all my stuff with just one hash board first. But, no, I wanna see them breaking because I really believe you only will really understand what you work with when you saw it fail. To our 2,000,000 listeners,
2,000,000 to 5,000,000 listeners, I think this is
exhibit a point and proof that it's a really smart idea to donate to the two five six Foundation so we can build a physical laboratory
because a lot of important work is coming out here of testing and and implementing new features. There's a lot still to do, but also giving that hands on tactile experience to other developers massively
change the status quo. Yeah. And not only right. You're also talking donating money, but I feel like we're also at a point that if you wanna donate hardware, please talk to us. Like, don't ship stuff
just without telling us.
But but no. I mean, like Get a pallet at your door? It it happened before.
That suddenly,
a truck showed up, and that's where my forklift is. And I was like, I have a back of my truck so we could push the pallet onto my truck. Yeah. Yeah. So
well, we're engineers. We're figuring it out. But no. Like, yeah. If you have some boards laying around that you don't need anymore or even whole miners. I mean, have received now. I got actually five
s 19 k hash boards
donated. I got a whole s 19 shipped to my house. So, yeah, if you have things,
talk to me through either Twitter and or probably through Twitter DMs. That's the easiest. Yeah. We can use it. Like I said, we unfortunately,
because a company decided to not make it open source, to not give us spec sheets about these my, mining chips, we need to break them in order to understand what they can do. And, yeah, I'm up for it. I have to I have the system to, I would say, make it safely. And, yeah, let's go and fucking build. Incredible. It's, you know, supporting this stuff is is a fantastic return on your investment. Right? I think we've already shown that, that we can provide a lot of value.
I mean, shout out to Riot for supporting you to work on this stuff. Right? Like, it's good for the ecosystem. It also is really good for them. Right? I mean, like, think of all the value they're getting. And and, actually, at the end of the day, how much cheaper it is Yeah. To develop this stuff on top of open source. So right. I mean, we literally reduced the hardware cost by around $200
now that we can deploy
directly on to the firmware. Right? And that's something that you figured out, Scott. Right? That's not so that's I I'm it's I know it's sometimes really hard to see why
should I invest into open source and whatever. But in this case, it literally reduced the unit cost of each of the of the units we're shipping by around $200 because we don't need like, the first version,
I was like, we need to install a Raspberry Pi or something
that can control this. Right? Because we cannot install anything on these miners. And then when Magina came, I was like, okay. Now we can actually do it even better because we assumed that we can control these chips even better than turning off and on all the time. So that was great. Then Scott figured out how to deploy Magina on it. And with that, we can now deploy the Nova control plane itself on it, and we can get rid of the Raspberry Pi. And so that's that's really, like, yeah, where open source literally saves dollars for every single unit that we're building. And and, yeah, if that's I don't know what other examples people need that, like, open source is the right way to go because it literally saves you money and and you gain so many more capabilities.
And the the whole cost of of building this system that Rides making too, comes down when you have these building blocks to work on or to point your AI agents at. Right? It just Yeah.
And the really cool thing, right, I'm in The US, and they are building it in Switzerland. So what actually happens is so I have a couple of s nineteens running here. They have a couple of s nineteens running over there, and I can point my agents running on my computer to theirs. So we have like a tail scale system that I can talk to their miners directly. And sometimes,
like in the beginning,
when I had to do really lot of work, yeah, I literally ran while I ran my agents to work on their through their night because during the day, it was way too loud to run these s nineteens. And yeah. So it's like even technology in general is is epic that we can now, across different continents, build hardware. That's like that's just fascinating to see. There was though, and there's also fun, like, whenever we test something new, we have like a Zoom call and they point the camera so I can see. And literally, the first time we did this, they connected everything. Oh, looks good. And suddenly, poof, two of the electric condensators exploded
because we switched the 12 volt on the control board. Funny enough for anybody to know, if you mix the 12 volt rails on an on an Bitmain AIM logic control board, you only destroy the fan controller. Everything else still works. So here's a tidbit. Not I mean, check your rails first, but no. It it it let out the magic smoke. And that was fun to see on a Zoom call, seeing, like, people scramble and turning off stuff.
That's fast mistake. That's awesome. That's awesome. Again, that's like, that's what I was saying. Like, you need to be willing to break stuff. If you're not willing to break stuff specifically with hardware, I mean, don't even start. Don't even try because you have to be willing to to get burned, to not dangerously hurt yourself. Like, obviously, like, be super careful, but it's gonna happen. Like, you cannot not do this. It's just specifically in the environment where we work with that we don't really know what these systems can do. So, yeah. And that's so that's my next step is the is the is the
fine tuning per chip. Some other ideas, right? There is actually three other control boards by Bitmain.
Mhmm. So we haven't done a lot of them, but I have one here. So this is a BeagleBone that is another control board than the regular AMLogix.
And then for the people that looked at my I I try to always hide some some Easter eggs. So a little hint, look at the control boards
on the pictures that I tweeted recently about the Nova setup. There's a black control board in there, and Bitmain has not created black control boards. So there is a company that has has a lot of brain that is building their own control boards,
and I got the Machina running on there. It's not fully tested yet, but soon
we're gonna have more support for more control boards because that's one of the other things. Right? Right now, we're telling everybody to find an AMLogic control board. And in the end, it shouldn't matter to which control board that you're deploying to. And, yeah, I mean, there's I have a thousand more ideas. If you have ideas, let us know or just let your agent know. And like I said, you will be surprised what it will come back with. Yeah. Take a peek at the repos. If you're nontechnical,
you can, reach out on the forum first and, have your agent read that.
Read the forum posts to get up to speed. Read the GitHub repos, and then start hacking away. How can people find out more about this, this solar system you're working on? So the company is called RYAT. It's ry3t.com.
The product is called Nova, and so it's their second product. They actually built the RYAT one first, which was an water heater, immersion based water heater. But they really see this opportunity with the solar
and monetization capabilities. So we're they launched a second product, the Riot Nova. You can actually preorder. So they are looking for preorders in Europe and also in The US. We're gauging interest, and you can sign up. You can tell us if you're interested there. So you can learn about this and then about all the open source and all the videos and all the proof. Yeah. That happens mostly on my Twitter slash account at schnitzel. There's a lot more to come over the next couple of days, like I mentioned, other control boards or other cool things. And then the code is on the two fifty six Foundation under Magina or
on my GitHub under Schnitzel Magina, but as mentioned, use at your own risk. I know this is all exciting, and I know everybody wants to try it out.
But, yeah, give give Ryan
some more time. He's actively testing. I'm shipping him actually some miners today so he can also test on his side. I really would wait to run this without safety precautions
until Ryan has merged this in and also tested on his side. And then the seventeenth, I got the event up here Friday
Washington DC, 7PM.
You and Scott are gonna be there riffing on some open source mining history, state of the industry. Great stuff. So if you're in the DMV area, make sure to to head over to PubKey and and see these guys in the flash. That should be really cool. We're also doing a Mining Monday event in Nashville on the July 27.
Nice. Evening. You have some more details coming out about that. I was looking at the pub word out there.
Yeah. Speaking of getting the word out there, I I think it's funny. On the pub key calendar on Luma. There's your guys' event, decentralized mining, a cypherpunk party on Friday, July 17. But tomorrow, July 16, it's with American Bitcoin talking about mega mining. So yeah.
Yeah. It's like back to back opposite ends of the industry. It'd be funny if if you guys could run into one another, you know, or or vice versa. Man, I would love to talk to them and be like, American Bitcoin mining running exclusively Chinese hardware and firmware. I see. Exactly. They'll come around to it eventually. Schnitzel's right. It's inevitable.
It is. Yeah. Generally I mean, I I talked to a lot of these people. Like, we we we talked to them at at at Bitcoin Las Vegas and things like that. And I think we also need to, like we just need to understand this that, like I mentioned, they have a lot of other issues. There was a lot of them are now pivoting into AI because their shareholders tell them to. But this also, again, like, this opens up a lot of new possibilities. Like, we heard Rafa from Electron at the tele or, like, at the Thames
that are saying, no. Like, we're not gonna go into AI, and they wanna optimize
fully, fully, fully on Bitcoin mining. And so I think it's also a bit of a time where we maybe flush out the people that weren't really Bitcoiners and just did it for the money's sake. So I don't think that's only bad for them to divest.
And I think the people that or the companies that will remain, they will all understand that open source is the only way to go, and I think that's a bright future. And for the ones that don't understand it, yep, go over in the AI world. I can tell you it's not easy over there. It's a lot harder. But That's a great point. I think there's a lot of large miners out there surviving today that just take the fact that these are machines. They buy them at face value. They plug them in, and Bitcoin comes out of them. As far as they're concerned, that's all they need to know.
Correct. Yep. Yeah. Yeah. Well, any other topics, gentlemen? Should we give a shout out to our hashers? Yeah. So I did not on purpose run my half a peta hash now just to have a good audio quality. But I'm trying now at every two fifty six when I know when it's getting recorded to be on top of the hashtash, but not today because,
like, odd you would hear a lot of noise in the background of me if I would try to do that. Half a petahash at your house. Wow. And your house is heated by miners. Right? Yes. Right now, I don't need to heat anything. Right. So I actually funny enough, I bought
a better air conditioning
to
Perfect.
Cool my garage more because I knew I'm gonna run a lot of miners in it. So, yeah, it's it's a bit stupid right now to basically heat the room to cool it down again. But what else you wanna do? I can't really run them outside. I don't think my neighbors would appreciate that. And so, yeah, they run inside and heat up my garage while I cool it. Sometimes you gotta do that. Shout out to Tesserae with over 50 terahash supporting the Hashrate HeatPunks and the two five six Foundation.
Longtime supporter, architecture firm out of Kansas, attendee of the HeatPunk Summit. Great guys over there. Zarca with a handful, a plethora of of Bidaxes on the network as well as Thack seven seven seven. Thank you. Then we got Iko with the Nerdax and his Apollo tried and true. Those have been supporting for a long time.
It's blocks.org,
myself with a couple mini miners, plus plus the best. We love you, Dee. Thank you for all you do
with the podcast and supporting us at the two five six Foundation. G's got a slim 19. We were actually gifted that. A cool design from the guys at Tesere. Their IT guy, Josh, made a really cool slim 19 that we've got. Backwater Mind Collective. 19.
There's a it's on the Heatpunk forum. It's a single board s 19, but it uses the standard fan, so it's really quiet. And it can run
up to, like, 800 watts, thousand watts.
Is it in the stock enclosure?
No. It's a fully three d printed enclosure, so it necks down and it gets really slim. Hence the name Slim 19. And it's got a cool handle, and it's it's awesome cable management. The PSU is, like, tucked in nicely. Like, it looks like a briefcase almost. It's got a handle on it. So that's great. Yeah. The CAD files were posted on the heatpunk forum. Forum.heatpunks.org.
Yeah. Check it out there. That's pretty cool. Is it a do is it a Loki rig? Like, is that how they're
because it has a smaller power supply? Yeah. It is. That's cool. I need a better, like, traveling miner. Feel like is that something great one for that.
Yeah. Right? That's what Shins and I were talking about the other day. It's just like, these miners are so big and heavy. There's, like, boat anchors. It really sucks to lug them around to events.
I'll put the link in the chat. Traveling miner. I like that. Yeah. When you want it's like in, like, a briefcase or something. Can just, like, you know, bring it This one literally has a handle on it. And flip it open and Yeah. It's like the president's football instead of, like, the nuclear launch code. It's like your personal miner.
I mean, it is funny. Right? Like, if you, like, if you go around, there's, like, there's plucks everywhere all the time. Like, why don't you just pluck in your miner? You can tether from your phone to get Internet access and just mine wherever you go. So Man, see some plugged into the wall. I see some interesting miner names on the hashtags here from you. Yeah. The Bidax proto is working, man. I just plugged it in, so the hash rate showing is a little bit low. It should be able to do about triple that once we get going here. But, yeah, Bidax proto with the
the Proto ASIC from Block is working. It's very exciting. Amazing. Amazing. And no desoldering required, I heard. No desoldering required. Data sheets.
When we were talking about tuning the chips, I was thinking about a lot of the work that I was doing yesterday on this. You can get
because they have they have temperature sensors per chip, they have voltage sensors per chip, but you can also get the hash rate of every core inside the ASIC. Oh. Woah.
And you can, you know, you can really start getting into tuning and they actually have, you know, so like with a Bitmain chip, you can set the hash frequency of the whole chip. And that frequency is set by something called a PLL, a phase lock loop. It's what generates the frequency.
These proto chips have four PLL's, so you can actually assign
a different clock rate to different cores within the chip. So you can have all the different cores pick one of four different hash frequencies to, like, do further tuning. It's really neat. Nice. That is super cool. Yeah. Excited to follow along with that development. I'm sure we'll hear much more soon. But Bidax Proto in the flesh, it's running, coming to you soon. Shout out to Satoki. Bitcoin Park still got a couple of Bidaxes pointed our way. I think we did that. We hijacked them. King of the hill. Yeah. Actually, that's a plan, Scott. Whenever we are a pop key, we need to hijack all the bid access that are sitting around there and point them to
our Yeah. Good idea. We we should do a script to just, like, find them and It already exists.
Of course, it does. Wherever I go, there's, like, a background script that just looks for Bidax. Is that right? Like, the olden days of, like, war driving, you know, where you go around and look for Wi Fi networks that you can join. This is, Turns out, like, like, you can now install stuff on these control boards. We should just, like, build a couple of control boards that look like a brain's control board, but it has, like, another software, and we just, like, drop them at becoming events and hope people will plug them in into their massive data centers before the and then it wakes up and sees all that. Just like but will they realize that, like, right, if you have 50 exahash,
will they know that, like, 1% of their hash rate is pointing somewhere else? I don't know. We'll see. Teach them a valuable lesson to don't trust verify.
Exactly. Why they need open source firmware so they can build patches to prevent that from happening. Yeah. There there's a lot of, like, interesting security implications
here that I think a lot of miners aren't you know, larger miners aren't used to thinking about at all. I mean They just kind of I don't know if watched what they've got. Sorry. I don't know. Yeah. If you watch mister robot, right, there's a multiple times where they do exactly that. So Yeah. Yes. That show's amazing. That's another thing. A rat team Bitcoin mining alliance to, like, attack miners. That would be another cool.
This is cypherpunk. I love it. Shout out to Woodminer. Love you, man. Thank you for the awesome plaques that you've gifted the two five six foundation and the Heatpunk Summit for our Heatpunk award. Legend, he dries his lumber with Bitcoin miners. Shout out to Nord, agent p with gridpool.net.
Go check that out. An awesome decentralized pool
and implementation.
Shout out to Jire. He's attending DC
He is. Friday. So,
you know, another good reason to come on down. You can talk to the man, the myth, the legend behind GridPool, and also really cool solar Bitcoin mining hardware, work that he's been doing. That's gonna be fantastic. Pizzandy with the proof of print bidaxe. Shout out to Pizzandy. I saw he just did a an enclosure redesign for the stealth miner that sat stacking plebs started, so that's cool. Go check that out. Shout out to Jair, all the work you do for Mugena.
Appreciate seeing you on the dev calls. Wicked smart dude. Shout out to Dylan, Pee Buttweiler, another Dylan. I got two Dylan's here. Oh, it's just a glitch. A nine and Schnitzel, man. That fish tank axe is struggling.
Back there. There it is. The heck there. It's the weakest miner we got. But it keeps my alert to the leaderboard.
is keeping Schnitzel's
3,030
exahashes
of loyalty leaderboard score
in the first place. Yeah. I mean, whenever Dylan comes close, I I wrote my minus a bit longer to just go ahead again. So He's still got triple him. Dang. No updates to the difficulty leaderboard. Electron's holding out with Wrigley and MEGAWatt just behind. Amazing dashboard built by Deep. It's so cool. Love it. It's so fun checking in periodically.
Also, if you wanna keep up with what the two five six Foundation and community is hacking on, check out the hashtag periodically because you'll see crazy system names. It's usually where we tease them. Right? Mhmm. The proto bit axe has been hashing there for a couple of days now, and someone might have seen that in advance or the combined
j and k stuff. Yeah. Was there for a couple of days. And If you know, you know. You can point your agents to it and check it out every couple of hours and look for cool names. Mhmm. It's a good way to hype your project. Right? We have between three and ten million
listeners. So, you know, send us some hash and, plug your project in the in the worker name. Mhmm. Alright, guys. Well, good luck on Friday. I'm excited to see hear how that event goes. We'll be there. Yeah. Keep your foot on the gas schnitzel. Amazing. I'm trying to. I'm a bit worried about my electrical bill this month, but I'm just gonna claiming on the AC. Yeah.
It's alright. You'll be you'll survive. Yes. And who knows? I mean, I'm also also making a little bit of fat with it, so I'm not I don't I don't hate it. Alright. That is Thanks, you guys. That is absolutely ready. Keep your foot on the gas. Can't stop. Won't stop. Cheers, everyone. Bye bye. Bye.